ghana's markets are why inflation buy
its hardest
here some goods are priced beyond the
reach of many customers
this is forcing shopper selection towel
to either reduce their food budgets or
take some items off the menu
i came to buy fish
and because of the price i'm asking
please please to reduce it and it's not
reducing it
and i think
i cannot buy so i'm going
because i'm having a cds and she said 16
cities and i cannot afford it at first i
it was uh aces and now it's 16.
so i don't know what to do about it she
puts much of the blame on traders such
as felicia paterno who in turn blames
producers and the government
for us a trader now the economy has
become so tight in such a way that
always the increase or the
brutalities come
in june thousands of people took to the
streets to demand the reversal of
government policies they say while
fueling inflation
between march and may this year ghana
central bank has raised interest rates
twice by at least 200 points each time
it was trying to rain inflation which is
currently at 27 percent
but along with a 15 drop in the value of
the local currency in the month of march
alone they haven't stopped the prices of
goats pushing far higher for most people
here
the government looking to the
international monetary fund for support
says it's intervening to help ghanaians
through the crisis
has it been enough many people will tell
you that we still feel a pinch because a
hundred percent on the global market
even if you take off some of the margins
will still translate into some
escalating prices at the fuel pumps
food prices continue to be a challenge
experts say unless ghana increases
domestic production and reduces imports
inflation will continue to rise
ahmed idris al jazeera accra